so you have to connect with them
culturally and socially hi there steve
kaufman here again and uh today i want
to talk about workplace english
if you enjoy these videos please
subscribe
click on the bell for notifications and
if you're following me on a podcast
service please leave a review
so
many people i know listen to my uh
videos
or even as a podcast to improve their
english
english is whether we like it or not
sort of the most widely used
international language
so there is a need
to learn english for work
this is particularly true of immigrants
to say canada the us uk australia
english-speaking countries who
have a need to work
in the sort of mainstream economy
therefore to use english or in the case
of canada french in the province of
quebec so
and and there are many if we google we
look for you know uh professional
english business english workplace
english
there are special programs courses that
are offered
to help people
you know improve their english for work
but i have some general sort of thoughts
on this
my own view is that
to work in english
the sort of technical
jargon the technical vocabulary that you
need
is rather limited
that can be learned quite easily
and
what i would do if i were say having to
work in german let's say or spanish or
chinese
or russian or japanese or portuguese
then i would find
you know documents
reports
things of that nature which have the
vocabulary the technical vocabulary that
relates to my
area of
professional uh you know expertise or
things that i need and i would read them
and i would if if i could find podcasts
on these subjects i would listen to them
i would save the words and phrases that
i need
essentially using something like link i
would bring them into link and then work
them to get that
jargon that turn of phrase the technical
terms that i need that's the easy part
the more difficult part is
because if you work
in a an office or you're interacting
with customers or suppliers or you're
dealing with people in a in a working
environment
you are dealing with them socially
you're dealing with them socially while
at work you're dealing with them in many
situations
socially after work
so you have to connect with them
culturally and socially that's more
difficult
so i always say you know the
professional english the business
english that's the easy part
work on improving your social english
and
fortunately today there's an abundance
of
sitcoms on youtube on netflix
uh there's different ways we can access
these to get at the
the phrasing that is being used
uh you know if we can get ourselves to a
stage where we actually get the jokes
uh
you know even the fact that we watch
some of the popular tv programs or see
the most recent movies it gives us a
subject of discussion that we can share
with our colleagues at work
um but also we can acquire the
vocabulary and get a sense of of the
culture
to the extent that these sitcoms reflect
how people actually live it's a somewhat
distorted
impression nevertheless
i find when i watch a sitcom in in
you know turkish or whatever i have a
feeling that i'm participating in in the
life of these people turkish people if
it's a family or whatever and i tend to
prefer sitcoms with
what seems to be realistic people rather
than
you know crime and
car car races and shooting and all this
kind of stuff so so we have to work even
in the workplace we have to work on our
social
english as well as our
uh professional english
now when it comes to sales presentations
or or making a print presentation of any
kind
i think it's
first of all you want to
study people who who are effective at
doing this and the interesting thing for
those people learning english is that
there is an abundance of podcasts on not
only on every possible area of from
marketing to technical issues to
uh you name it bitcoin i don't know
there's there's podcasts on everything
uh and there's podcasts on history and
there's podcasts on whatever subject
you're interested in so i would
definitely recommend availing yourself
of podcasts
but also
i'm sure i don't know if there are
podcasts on how to make a presentation
but there's lots of i haven't googled
for it but if you google for how to make
a presentation you get lots of tips
my suggestion is in any presentation i
have made
i
use the sort of presentation techniques
of the ancient greeks and romans the
sort of rhetorical conventions and you
can google rhetoric
and you will see that they have a
certain style you begin by
you have to begin by
making people like you in a way and
establishing your credentials and then
you tell a story and then you can
present some counter arguments to your
story and then you want to finish with
an emotional appeal i mean i've
summarized it very quickly but i would
definitely recommend
that you do some research into how to
present things effectively and there are
a number of conflicting theories of how
to present effectively but these are
techniques that you should have because
if you have
a technique that you're using for how
you are going to present how you're
going to
make yourself appear credible how you're
going to lead the audience one way and
then lead them another way and then
conclude in some other way then you have
the feeling that you are in control and
that is a very powerful feeling
when you are trying to persuade people
of something so to summarize then uh by
all means
uh and and once we're talking about
workplace english in most cases we're
talking about people who are beyond the
sort of beginner level these are people
who have a certain level in the language
who need to improve that level but
beyond that want to feel comfortable in
the workplace so my advice in summary is
by all means find technical
documents articles
material books podcasts that you can
access in order to get the technical
jargon and phraseology that you need
or for that matter if you if you have to
write papers there are forms that or
structures that should be used in making
you know presenting your dissertation or
whatever it might be
but then
make sure you put enough effort into the
social cultural language so that you can
be comfortable with your colleagues at
work
whether at work or after work and there
are any number of ways you can do that
because nowadays there's just so much
material available on the internet even
if you don't live in say an
english-speaking country you can access
that kind of environment through netflix
youtube and
other you know maybe presentations that
are available on on the internet
and finally if you are in the situation
where you have to make sales
presentations
do a little bit of research on effective
you know speech making and and rhetoric
as i say r-h-e-t-o-r-i-c
because the ancient greeks and romans
really had a good uh approach it was a
big part of of their education
and i think is very valuable even today
so there you have it a brief
discussion on workplace english and
it is part of this whole idea of
effective output so i will leave a
couple of videos where i talk about
using the language effectively